He did say something. He said as
Orthodox Jews
as Orthodox Jews
we can't enter a church.
But he didn't explain why.
And Lord willing when I do a review I
may do a review I'll explain to you why.
But I don't want to say it now. I don't
want to go by memory.
He didn't explain why they don't enter
the church.
Can you guys guess why?
Let me double Let me fact check. And
then we're going to get into some of the
topics cuz they're not here. They
carried away.
All right. Orthodox Jews. Let me just
see something.
Okay, I just don't want to say it. I
want to
All right.
Here. Just say I did Sheikh Google the
greatest scholar ever lived.
Traditionally Jews and especially
Orthodox Jews do not enter churches as
to avoid avodah zarah foreign worship.
Because in other words your churches are
considered like temples.
Pagan temples cuz you worship foreign
gods.
See that?
But guess what he didn't say.
Guess what he didn't say.
My rabbi says it is forbidden for Jews
to enter a church. But if we can't
participate in different businesses how
can we promote promote understanding
between different faiths? Rabbi Naftali
Brower
Your rabbi is correct. The rabbinic
consensus based on the talmud avodah
zarah
So it is that it's forbidden to enter a
church even to just admire the
architecture or artwork. Now I'm glad he
gave us Avodah Zarah cuz we're going to
look at it.
I wonder why. Now, watch being
politically correct sugarcoat it so not
to lose the support of Christian
Zionists. This body of opinions spans
the generations of com- com-
comprises leading medieval Sephardic and
Ashkenazi rabbis such as Maimonides,
Rashba, Rabbi Solomon ben Adret, Ritba,
Rabbi Yom Tov ibn Azavili, and Rosh
Rabbi Asher ben Yechiel.
As well as contemporary halakhists
including Rabbis Moshe Feinstein,
Ovadia Yosef, and Eliezer Waldenberg.
While at first glance this approach
appears disrespectful to and even
disdainful of other faiths, I believe
it's just the opposite. You see the
sugarcoating, the political correctness?
Okay?
Judaism sees any faith
as something very powerful. Christian
house of worship in Jewish eyes is more
than just a building. It is a place
where Christianity is palpable. But
wait,
why don't you tell them why you don't
enter? Because you think Christianity is
idolatrous cuz they worship three gods
and worship a man.
Do you understand?
Why didn't he mention that?
Wasn't the tribe of Dan one of the fr-
Oh my goodness. Auzubillah Muhammad
Ar-Rajim. According to the book of
Judges, but can Jews enter mosques?
Can Orthodox Jews
enter
mosques?
Yes.
Orthodox Jews can enter mosques. You see
how they're spitting on Christians?
See it?
Why didn't that Orthodox Jew say that to
Sean McDowell?
Guys,
don't be stupid.
You live in the age of the internet.
Everything is there, free, accessible.
If you don't want to pay for internet,
use your neighbor's internet.
Does Islam allow Jews? Yeah, we know
that. Yes, Orthodox Jews can and
generally enter mosques, and it's
permitted to pray in them, unlike
churches, which are forbidden.
The distinction is because Islam is a
monotheistic religion, so mosques are
not considered houses of idol worship of
Avodah Zarah, but churches are. And the
same way churches are by most Orthodox
opinions.
There you go.
All right, Halacha Yomit question, may a
Jew enter a mosque or church when there
is a need to do so or to visit there as
a tourist? The great Rambam in his
commentary on the Mishnah Masechet
Avodah Zarah
deduces from the words of the Mishnah
there regarding an actual house of idol
worship. Notice, idol worship, that we
are almost forbidden to look at it, let
alone enter it. The words of the Rambam
are quoted by
quoted as Halacha
by the Shach Yoreh De'ah chapter 149, as
well as
the other [clears throat]
Acharon
Acharonim,
sorry guys, I'm trying to see.
The Tosafot in Masechet Avodah Zarah
right, so deduce from the Gemara Gemara
that one must distance himself even from
the entrance of a house of idol
worship as much as possible.
Similarly, Maran Ha Shulchan Aruch in
Yoreh De'ah, chapter 150, section 1,
rules that there's a mitzvah to
distance. There's a good deed to
distance oneself
four amot, approximately 6.5 ft from a
path of idol worship. Thus, if one is
walking close to a house of idol
worship, such as a church,
one should distance himself
at least four amot from the entrance to
this place, for it is well known that
Christian churches are considered
houses of idol worship as they believe
in another deity besides for Hashem. If
so, it is certainly forbidden to
actually enter their churches for they
are actual
houses of idol worship.
Why didn't he tell that to Sean
McDowell?
Why did he say that to Sean McDowell?
What's up, doc?
The evil spirit found [snorts]
in houses of idol worship. So, your
church is a
house of idol worship and you have evil
spirits there. You see it?
Based on this, it is clear that it's
forbidden to enter a Christian church
for a church is a house of idol worship
as we have explained.
So, your churches have evil spirits in
it.
See it?
Let me get you the link so you don't
think I'm making it up.
This is what he did not tell Shawn
McDowell.
Then you still want to bend over
backwards
for people like Tovia Singer? I don't I
want to be careful. I don't want to
generalize.
Not every Orthodox Jew knows this
tradition. Not every Orthodox Jew is
educated about Christianity.
We don't want to generalize, demonize
everyone. Be careful.
But you see it, right?
Does that bother you guys?
Does that bother you guys? What about a
mosque, though?
Installing air conditions in a mosque
church. Entering a Muslim mosque.
Regarding entering mosque, the Rambam
explains in one of his responsa that
Ishmaelites are not considered idol
worshipers. Can you believe it?
Muslims who worship Allah of the Quran
are not idol worshipers, but Christians
are.
Since they believe in Hashem.
So Allah of the Quran is their God.
See that?
See that right there?
I know I haven't enlarged it. I gave you
the link, but here, I'll put it right
here.
Okay.
I guess it it reversed the order.
Let's see.
Yeah, I guess it didn't Okay, I'll write
here. Entering a Muslim uh regarding
entering a mosque, the Rambam
explains in one of his responsa that
Ishmaelites are not considered idol
worship worshipers
since they believe in Hashem and there
is no denial of Hashem in their
religion. See why Tovia Singer
bends over backwards for Muslims and
works with them or anything else that
should cause them to be considered idol
worshipers.
We are therefore lenient and sell our
lands in Israel to Muslims during the
Shemitah
sabbatic
right?
Sabbatical
year based on the heter mechira process,
although it is forbidden to sell land in
Eretz Yisrael. Meaning, if they had
their way, you wouldn't have a church in
Israel. You understand? To an idol
worshiper. This is because Muslims are
not considered idol worshipers.
Based on this, mosques are not
considered actual houses of idol
worship, and one may enter them
according to the letter of the law.
What about churches though? Here's a
summary.
So, if they had their way, would there
be churches in Israel? No. Niet.
It is absolutely forbidden to enter a
house of idol worship. Included in this
prohibition is entering a Christian
church
or other kinds of houses of idol worship
in the Far East.
Nevertheless, there is no
halakhic prohibition to enter
a Muslim mosque.
Especially true when this is being done
in order to pray there. You can pray in
a mosque
such as at the graves of our forefathers
in the Machpelah Cave in Hebron.
Did someone pass the memo to Apostate
Prophet? Apostate Prophet, I know you
watch me. What are you going to say
about this, buddy?
>> Are you guys shocked by this?
How many of you are shocked by this?
Isn't it outrageous and sad
and heartbreaking
that the Muslims are closer to
Christians
and their love, devotion, and respect
for Jesus and Mary as mother than
Orthodox Judaism?
Isn't it heartbreaking? And can you
mention one of these Christian Zionist
YouTubers, evangelicals
sharing this with you?
It's easy to demonize Muslims
and hate them and their religion
saying Allah is a foreign god, whereas
the Christian Zionist who worship Israel
are being told by the Orthodox Jews in
their
authentic, official
teaching, halakha, law, right?
That your churches are houses of
idolatry. They're defiled. There are
evil spirits there cuz you don't worship
Hashem, but foreign gods.
But masjids on the other hand, they are
true houses of worship because they
worship Hashem there.
What's going on with you Christians,
man? How long you going to be asleep?
Does it need to take someone like me
to mention it? Oh, but you're
anti-Semitic.
No, I'm not, man. I just told you
about me being reconnected to this young
Jewish boy who's a grown man whose
family I love.